early in the morning
Turkish US and Croatian soldiers climb
aboard a helicopter as its Georgian
pilots wait to takeoff Kristiana
Bundeswehr captain is among this very
international group at 7:00 we fly over
mazar-e-sharif
on the way to an Afghan army camp
Christian isn't a non-combat role he's
an advisor one of around 150 German
soldiers here to provide support to
their Afghan colleagues for me it's
especially satisfying when I see how
committed the Afghan soldiers are to
building a safe Afghanistan 5,000 Afghan
soldiers are based here they take part
in combat missions throughout the north
of the country Afghanistan is at war and
has been so for decades these soldiers
have never seen peace and they want to
make a difference but they also have to
be prepared for the worst in 2014 alone
the Afghan army lost as many soldiers as
the International ISIL forces did in 13
years the German military base at the
other end of the city looks deserted
once there were more than 5,000 German
soldiers in Afghanistan now there are
only 850 Germans have served here for 13
years while the situation has improved
the Taliban has not been defeated the
globins theater I think we lacked
experience for this kind of operation
Afghanistan went through a civil war
that lasted 30 years we never had
anything like that we didn't know what
to expect here the German military says
Afghanistan needs more time no one knows
how
this new mission will last